Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, I hope you all
had a chance to see episode 1.
I asked you all to submit questions in my
review video, so I picked 10 of them to answer
in this video and one bonus question.
First thing’s first though.
Congratulations to Anna Ees, you’re the
first winner of my weekly giveaway.
You win a $20 amazon gift card.
If you’re international it’s just paypal.
I’ll be reaching out to you on your channel
for details.
Round two of the giveaway begins when I post
my episode 2 review.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
all you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on those videos.
And be nice to everyone.
So let’s answers some questions.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you’re
not caught up.
Also during question five I talk a lot about
Jon Snow’s supposed parents, even though
the books haven’t said who they are, everyone
has their theories.
So if you want to avoid that, just watch for
the spoiler warning and then skip ahead in
the video.
Here we go.
Question 1 - Cleetus Van Damme asks Are there
any references to the Thenns being cannibals
in the books?﻿
I believe that the Skagos tribes were the
cannibals in the books, but because they didn’t
want to have to cast more people they just
gave that trait to the Thenns.
Remember when Jon Snow was telling the Night’s
Watch council about the Wildling Army.
It’s a hundred thousand strong, so there’s
no way they can portray all those people.
If we do get to see them this season, they’ll
probably do a lot of CG crowd duplication.
Question 2 - Ray Ray asks Based on this episode,
how well do you think that they will stick
to the book?﻿
DB Weiss and David Benioff are really committed
to honoring the original text, so all the
major sign posts will be there.
And for anyone who’s read the books, all
the biggest stuff will always be there.
It’s just the smaller things that they have
to combine or omit all together.
Like the Ser Dontos scene.
In the books it was a hairnet but on the show
it was a necklace.
That’s a minor change, with Arya and the
Hound who knows.
In one of the trailers we saw her in the middle
of a training montage with Needle.
That’s probably from the first couple of
episodes.
I don’t think they’ll totally change her
story from the books, but there are always
the Shae exceptions.
When I say that, I mean they can choose to
keep characters they feel work really well
together, in more scenes than they had in
the books.
So thus we could see more Hound and Arya palling
their way to the Vale than was in the books.
Question 3 - Vegtabadass asks if the dragons
keep growing, could they get as big as Smaug
from The Hobbit?
I saw a fictional dragon size chart that listed
Smaug as the biggest fictional dragon ever
created.
Like as big as an apartment complex.
The biggest dragon in the history of Westeros
was Balerion the Black Dread.
Aegon the Conqueror's dragon.
There are a lot of things about Daenerys and
her three dragons that mirrors Aegon, his
two sisters and their three dragons.
For instance, their three dragons were the
same colors as Daenerys.
So I think George RR Martin is implying that
Drogon will be just like Balerion.
He’s still very young.
Balerion lived to about two hundred years
old.
But remember, he had no natural predators.
When Aegon first brought them to Westeros,
they were essentially unchallenged.
I think now there are more people like Tyrion
and other Maesters who are educated on dragonlore.
Their size is just a function of food supply
and age.
So the longer the live and the more they eat,
the more they grow.
Question 4 - Stephen Herman asks Do you like
how they changed Arya and The Hound from the
book?
I do like it, The Hound and Arya are one of
the best pairs on the show.
It’s hard to tell if they’ll stay completely
faithful to the books, but until we see otherwise
let’s just assume that the biggest events
will still happen the way they’re supposed
too.
I guess if they ended up doing something radically
different from the books it wouldn’t be
terrible.
The writing is great and the actors are amazing.
So no matter what I’ll keep watching.
I don’t get upset when they drop characters
or eliminate things.
Careful for spoilers in this one.
I basically try to connect the dots on who
Jon Snow’s mother is, so if you don’t
want to know.
Just skip ahead in the video about 30 seconds.
Question 5 - All The World’s A Stage actually
pointed something out that I wanted to include.
When you freeze frame on the White Book page
for Gerold Hightower it tells some more of
the backstory of what happened to Lyanna Stark.
Hightower was the commander of the Kingsguard
before Barristan Selmy.
He was in charge when Jaime murdered King
Aerys during Robert’s rebellion.
Before he died, King Aerys sent Hightower
and a couple of men to find Rhaegar when he
ran off with Lyanna Stark.
He found the two at the Tower of Joy which
was in the North part of Dorne.
Rhaegar left and made Hightower stay behind
to guard Lyanna, eventually Eddard Stark found
them and ended up killing Hightower and his
men.
When they found Lyanna she was lying in a
bed of blood.
This is where all the Jon Snow theories come
from.
The implication is that when Hightower found
Rhaegar and Lyanna, she was pregnant, so Rhaegar
asked Hightower to stay and guard her.
She died as a result of the childbirth and
Eddard Stark got there just as Jon Snow was
being born.
He took him and to protect him, named him
his own bastard.
Thus he’s a Son of Ice and Fire.
So that’s what that page in the White Book
is all about.
Oberyn Martell’s comments corroborate some
of the theory.
Question 6 - No Sherlock asks Are we going
to see any other Martell’s this season?
There isn’t a lot of Dorne as a geographical
location in Book 3, so I don’t think we’ll
see it a lot or the other Martells until season
5.
Think of it in terms of Daenerys journey to
different cities in the east.
Each season she goes to more and more places.
So eventually we’ll see plenty of Dorne.
It’s really different from the rest of Westeros
so I can’t wait.
There’s a lot of really cool characters
they can potentially introduce.
Question 7 - Hyrule Savior Asks Is Oberon
Daenerys’ Uncle?﻿
No, Daenerys is the youngest child of King
Aerys, her mother was also a Targaryen.
Remember all the sister wiving they did.
She’s first cousins with the Martells.
Prince Doran’s sister was Elia, who married
Rhaegar.
Oberyn is Doran’s younger brother.
Question 8 - Jesse Wade asks Do you feel that
Arya is maturing as a character in much the
same way that Carl is in TWD?﻿
Yes, but their characters are headed in opposite
directions.
They’re both at a crossroads so to speak.
Appropriate since, Arya was just literally
at the crossroads.
Carl is trying to decide whether or not he’s
becoming a monster and he doesn’t want to
be, he’s trying to stay a good person.
Arya on the other hand is embracing the dark
path she’s on.
She’s slowly turning into a killer and is
really enjoying the thought of that.
For her it means revenge.
Question 9 - Dex asks Which character’s
story are you most excited to see this season?
In no particular order, Tyrion Lannister,
Jon Snow, Bran Stark and Arya.
Without going further, I feel like there are
so many interesting things happening this
season it’s hard to pin down just one character.
Question 10 - Pseudo Nym asks Episode 2 the
Rose and the Lion sounds like the Purple Wedding,
is that true?
Yes, from trailer for next week it looks like
we’ll see all the wedding scenes.
They said it was the biggest shoot since the
season 1 premiere in terms of number of people
on set those days.
Charles Dance said the wedding and the banquet
after felt like a short film all by itself
just because it was so elaborate.
and one last Bonus Question - Silver blaze
mist asks How about the Ser Duncan the Tall
Shout out?
Yes, also from the White Book.
When Joffrey is flipping through it he talks
about Ser Duncan the tall.
From the Dunk and Egg spinoff books that George
RR Martin wrote.
You should read them if you haven’t I talk
about them a bunch in the Game of Thrones
Movie video I did a while ago.
I’ll add a link to that at the end of this
video.
But thanks so much for submitting questions.
This season is going to be so much fun.
It’s going to be hard to talk about everything
without going crazy on spoilers, so I’ll
always try to provide clear warnings for anyone
that wants to just skip over stuff.
Also heads up, I’m going to start doing
game of thrones bonus videos on Sunday mornings
just to get us all pumped up for each new
episode.
You can leave me suggestions for what to do
them on in the comments.
Right now learn all about Ser Duncan the tall
here and you can click here for my review
of episode 1.
Thanks for watching, see you tomorrow.
High Fives!